and so you see logically pizza planet is
the only franchise that could have been
used in the legacy recipe from freddy
fazbear's which is how you get matpat
mr matpath yes do you have a theory oh
my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh it's
totally happening they're finally
acknowledging my existence um uh um
do i have a theory uh yes yes sir i do
about the future of the mcu oh yeah and
not just about the future but also the
old great i've got kevin feige and i've
got a cease and desist
oh
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that can predict the future of
the marvel cinematic universe 90 percent
of the time
oh
hey no need to show me up like that
morris then again how can i stay mad at
something with such a cute fuzzy f legs
so shongshi is finally out on disney
plus meaning that those who weren't
comfortable going to see it in the
theaters are finally getting to
experience the best marvel phase 4 movie
yet to be fair the competition so far
hasn't been particularly hard between
the incredible choreography the
brilliant character performances the
decided lack of a sky beam yeah this one
felt really refreshing especially when
the whole climax just amounts to one big
kaiju battle speaking of those giant
monsters at the end though that one felt
weird for you too right like you have
this incredible movie featuring top tier
martial arts and then giant cgi tentacle
monster alright sure the dweller in
darkness as this big third act villain
just felt weird to me both when i first
saw it in theaters again when i watched
it at home like why him it felt so
random so disconnected from everything
the movie had set up tonally up to that
point but then disney plus day happened
and with it all these announcements
about upcoming projects and suddenly
something clicked into place for me you
see i believe shangshi's inclusion of
the dweller in darkness has set the
dominoes up for the biggest reveal that
the mcu has left one that they've been
keeping in their back pocket since 2019
shangshi and the giant kaiju battle it
just opened the door both figuratively
and literally for the x-men strap in
friends this is gonna be a wild ride to
give the briefest of recap so you can
follow the important details for today's
theory shongxi follows a character named
chongqi if that wasn't obvious but the
story is really all about his father
wenwoo the mandarin and you'll never see
me coming not that one the real mandarin
you see when woo for being a cold
heartless international crime lord is
really broken up about his dead wife so
when he hears her suddenly calling out
to him from behind a mysterious door he
becomes obsessed with opening that door
back up after decades of searching he
finds the door in the realm tallow and
the people there are totally like no you
idiot that's not your wife that's a big
bad dark thing that we sealed behind the
door years ago which can i just say why
like why do people seal entities behind
doors and not you know a wall you're not
meant to open a wall walls do not come
with hinges that allow them to open back
up just saying you had one job tallow
one job and you blew it anyway chongxie
the movie decides to be very efficient
in its third act by combining all of its
tropes into one major battle not only do
shangshi and wenmu have a good
old-fashioned mcu fight your opposite
color scheme nemesis battle but it's
also a punch through your daddy issues
battle two for the price of one really
appreciate how they've streamlined the
process anyway the battle is promptly
interrupted by something bursting
through the door and funnily enough it's
not wenwu's wife this giant monster is
called the dweller in darkness when
moose sacrifices himself for his son and
shengshi manages to use the rings to
destroy the dweller despite it being the
first time that he's ever tried him on
and the fact that talos best warriors
were unable to do the same task
millennia ago just saying watch out
captain marvel looks like we got a
totally new overpowered hero auditioning
for the avengers and that's basically
the movie this is obviously a massive
oversimplification of what actually goes
down but it's basically what we need to
know to contextualize the dweller in
darkness this giant cthulhu-like
tentacle monster thing that eats souls
in order to become more powerful as i
mentioned before it felt like a weird
inclusion to me for a movie all about
hand-to-hand combat the dweller feels
like a bad fit for a kung fu movie feels
like something more in line with like a
cosmic mystic arts movie and if you
thought the same thing then
congratulations you're right because the
dweller in darkness is in the comics but
not as a shongxi character instead he's
one of the oldest and most fearsome foes
to none other than dr strange that guy
keeps showing up in weird places these
days doesn't he it also explains why
they shoehorned wong in there you see in
the comics the dweller in darkness is a
demonic being who claims to have been
born of the essence of all fears he
tends to lead a sewing circle of other
scary monsters called the fearlords
they're kinda like edgelords but scarier
normally he looks like this literally an
octopus on a body clearly his appearance
in legend of the 10 rings has changed a
lot now looking a lot more like a dragon
bat dinosaur thing but he and his
minions do still have those telltale
lovecraftian old one tentacles something
that we've also been seeing a lot in
these marvel phase four projects what if
for instance has not just one random
appearance of tentacles but two in both
episode one with captain carter and
episode four with doctor strange so we
have doctor strange himself his enemies
and lots and lots of tentacles coming
out of portals all over the mcu right
now in shanghi in what if in the
upcoming spider-man movie in his own
multiverse movie down the line but what
does it all mean and why do i think it
all connects back to the x-men well
that's where this scene and disney plus
day come in if you don't know what
disney plus day was it was basically a
day where disney released a bunch of
stuff onto their streaming service and
then made announcements about upcoming
projects and of the announcements there
was a lot of what you'd expect more mcu
more star wars more pixar even some
surprises like hocus pocus 2 which gotta
say personal favorite of mine just lots
and lots of stuff coming down the
pipeline for disney but you know it was
oddly quiet fox properties specifically
the x-men for those of you who don't
remember or weren't aware of it disney
bought fox two and a half years ago and
with it came the rights to another
marvel property the x-men but nothing
has come of it no announcements no hints
about upcoming projects and sure it
takes time to make stuff but you know
these things run on hype stuff gets
announced years before it ever becomes a
reality the mcu has a timeline that's
like five years out at this point or in
the world of video games you got elder
scrolls six which was announced three
years ago with nothing to show for it
but a stock fantasy image pulled the
night before by an intern you'd think
that disney would mention something that
they're planning to do with this massive
ip that they paid 71 billion dollars for
oh oh wait hold on at disney plus day
they they did announce one thing and
it's kind of random a reboot of the
1990s fox animated classic the x-men now
dubbed x-men 97 which hey if nothing
else gives me an excuse to fire up this
old intro from five years ago that we
spent way too long on and only used once
[Music]
oh that theme song it's so good anyway
people went nuts over this thing and i
gotta admit i was excited too i loved
watching this show growing up but
something felt suspicious to me about
this announcement like this is the one
and only thing that's first out of the
gate for x-men under disney control i
mean sure it's the classic but is it
really big enough to be given this sort
of treatment why not just reboot the
live-action x-men and get them into the
mcu i mean that's what everybody really
wants that's where the big money is not
on streaming we all know it and i
guarantee you disney knows it too that's
why i suspect x-men 97 is gonna be the
x-men's introduction into the mcu just
none the way that people might expect
see in the 90s the x-men animated series
was hugely popular and it introduced a
whole new audience to these characters
the issue was the comics available at
the time didn't look anything like the
cartoon and a lot of the characters that
seemed important in the animated series
like jubilee and gambit just weren't
like at all so marvel wanted there to be
something in the x-men section of comic
book stores that actually resembled the
version of the x-men that these tv show
fans were more familiar with as such
they published a separate series
disconnected from the rest of the marvel
universe continuity that adapted the
storylines from the show under the title
x-men adventures when the cartoon was
due to end they then rebranded this
comic as adventures of the x-men which
told new stories still set in the
original continuity of the cartoon tying
off most of its ongoing plot threads the
key for us today though is how the
series ended they didn't settle for the
world was saved and they all lived
happily ever after in this one oh no
friends they went insane and actually
ended the entire universe you heard that
right not sure how to end a series just
end the universe no more characters
means no more stories to tell this story
arc was driven largely by a character
named despair who turns out was working
on behalf of another character the one
that started this whole theory the
dweller in darkness yep the dweller
wanted to end the universe because doing
so would cause everyone to feel immense
fear fear that he could then absorb and
basically become a god the crazy twist
with this story though is that the x-men
don't really manage to stop him well
it's kind of like a tie they can't stop
the destruction of the universe but they
did learn enough about understanding
brotherhood and friendship over the
course of the series that jean grey's
phoenix powers are able to send those
positive vibes to every mind and
existence so no one is afraid of their
inevitable death they're all connected
so even though they're on the brink of
armageddon they die nobly without fear
meaning that the dweller doesn't get the
opportunity to level up and then the
known universe collapses in on itself
and everyone dies the end but what on
earth does this have to do with the mcu
well out of the end of their universe
comes a big bang which creates a whole
new universe the real comic universe
universe 616. on the last panel we see
the classic 1960s versions of the x-men
essentially rebooting the animated x-men
but in a way that then connected them
back into the main continuity of the
franchise this is actually what i
predict is going to happen at the end of
x-men 97. remember this part of the
story was never put to screen it was a
totally new story just for the comics
which makes it a pretty darn great
choice for all of those who wanted the
tv show to get its true finale but it
also means that marvel can have their
cake and eat it too they can revive
these classic characters keeping them as
cartoons but also throw them into the
mcu by having him be a prequel to the
marvel universe that we know today in
shangxi we hear that before the dweller
was locked away by talo he had destroyed
many universes maybe one such universe
was the x-men 97 one that may seem like
a stretch but if you cast your mind back
to the spider-man no way home teaser
you'll notice that doctor strange is
holding a conspicuous mug emblazoned
with a cartoon fox it could just be a
random mug that they had on set or it's
another easter egg fox formerly owned
the rights to properties like the x-men
the fantastic four and deadpool hence
why they've never appeared in the mcu
but now that disney owns fox people have
been hoping that any multiversal
storyline would allow characters like
the x-men to suddenly enter into the
continuity it's why everyone got so
excited when x-men's quicksilver turned
up in wandavision and then did a
collective eye roll when it turned out
to be a fake i think this mug is a nod
to the connection between doctor strange
and fox's x-men 97 which so far is the
only fox marvel property to be announced
plus we know that doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness has a big
co-starring part for scarlet witch a
character with a major quasi-canonical
connection to the x-men universe and
this is the part where i remind you that
in xiangxi the mcu's dweller in darkness
tricked wenwoo into releasing it by
calling out to him using the voice of
his dead wife all while when wu was in
an emotionally vulnerable state
researching dark magic and using the ten
rings remind me again what scarlet witch
was doing the last time that we saw her
[Music]
she too was in an emotionally vulnerable
state researching dark magic when she's
startled by the voices of none other
than her dead children so x-men 97 may
just be a canonical prequel to the mcu
but if the dweller in darkness has been
defeated in the mcu timeline then surely
our connection is gone then right well
not quite because there is another
massive villain that comes out of that
x-men storyline you see there's one
other person racing to survive the death
of the universe a scientist astronaut
named galin from an advanced planet
called tah like the x-men he too was
undertaking a desperate mission to try
and prevent the universe's collapse
instead he becomes the sole survivor for
his entire galaxy and he merges with the
sentience of the universe in order to
transform into a god-like being that's
always hungry for planets in short this
one story gives us the birth of galactus
one of the most important and powerful
comic book forces of all time a giant
space dude with a cool hat who eats
planets not because he's evil but
because he's just really hungry he is an
embodiment of a literal force of nature
basically the final boss of marvel
properties now a few years ago this guy
showing up wouldn't have fit into the
more realistic sensibilities of the mcu
but now that the mcu has introduced
giant cosmic entities like the
celestials a big boy like galactus could
possibly fit right in scratch that it's
more than a possibility i believe it
actually is what's gonna happen and this
newfound confidence all comes back to
shangshi the most important part of this
movie actually comes down to the
mid-credits scene because of course it
does it's a marvel movie hmong explains
that when shangshi used the ten rings
himself for the very first time he and
the other mystics felt it in kamertage
where previously they had had no record
of anything like them ever existing
despite the fact that when wu had been
using these things for a thousand years
apparently extending his life conquering
kingdoms and killing tons of people with
his magic floaty blue rings wasn't
enough magic stuff for the society of
wizards tasked with noticing magic usage
to you know notice the magic you had one
job wong you sit over there with talo
twice in the same episode i'm not mad
just disappointed mom goes on to explain
that using the rings was like setting
off a beacon calling out to something or
someone out in the cosmos
a beacon or sending a message now in a
previous theory i proposed that the ten
rings could match up with the ten
eternals that we're aware of before the
movie's release and sure enough eternals
does feature a climactic battle scene
where the eternal engineer fastos
invents a way for the team to captain
planet their energies together into a
singular force called the unimine using
flashing important stuff arrow here
special bracelets that each individual
eternal wears so
these then are the ten rings that when
woo found right no because by that point
in the movie two of the ten eternals had
been killed off that would leave um and
minus two is um less than ten also that
scene happens in the present time so you
know those 10 rings that ain't it chief
so it's not the eternals it's not the
dweller of darkness who is it you've
probably figured out where i'm going
with this one it's galactus think about
it we know that marvel likes to combine
or mix up their stories a little bit so
where the dweller in darkness is more
traditionally a doctor strange villain
he's now been defeated to be replaced by
the other big bad from his x-men
continuity it's also worth mentioning
that galactus has been seen clashing
with another set of characters from the
fox marvel pantheon the fantastic four
what better way to reboot all of them
and bring them into the mcu than with
one of their biggest villains and don't
forget we've already met one of our new
phase four villains kang the conqueror
over in loki and his main bad guy thing
is getting yourself a space monster
that's always hungry and feeding it i
weaponized a liar sounds familiar kind
of like a certain universe-sized villain
with a cool hat and an appetite for
planets so there you have it friends i'm
suggesting that the fox universe has to
die so the mcu can be born both
canonically but i suppose also from a
meta standpoint you can have our cartoon
x-men and it still actually means
something to the mcu the universe
collapses bookending the fox era of
marvel history while still having it fit
in nice and neat with their mcu but in
doing so they're able to create a
monster worse than the dweller in
darkness one that the ten rings are
calling out to like a lunch bell drawn
galactus to earth for our heroes to
fight against at the end of phase four
or probably actually later in phase five
alongside some new heroes like the
rebooted x-men that we'll see at the end
of the adventures comics but hey that's
just a theory a film theory and cuts
[Music]